A good hair stylist
is indispensable.
My guy Sean--
had him for 20 years
we've been working together.
He's the reason I look
like a dapper little hunk boy
-instead of a raggedy dandy.
-(laughter)
But one of the best parts
of getting your hair did
is the hot goss that happens.
Who's dating whom,
who's leaving whom,
who insists on saying "whom"
'cause
it's grammatically correct
even though it sounds
pretentious as (bleep).
And nothing shows
this chitchat off better
than this adorable viral video
of a woman and her hairdresser,
captioned "Salon Talk."
And then I told him,
"Is you crazy?"
Is you crazy?
Girl, he kept it right.
-Kept it right.
-Crazy.
Girl, I'm trying to tell you.
-I'm trying to tell you.
-Ain't he crazy?
-He crazy.
-Girl.
Girl.
-(laughter, cheering, applause)
-Come on!
Come on!
My ovaries just moved!
(laughter)
Right there,
she's giving Mommy an updo do.
So, comedians,
this mom didn't really
ask her hairdresser anything.
So, as the next client
of this baby stylist,
get the scoop on her life.
-Dulcé. -Girl, what's new
in your life, solid food?
-Okay, I see you.
-(laughter, applause, cheering)
Points.
-Jon. -Girl, what do you do
to make your ass look so fat?
Oh, you (bleep) your pants.
Awesome. That's great.